Jesus christ founded his
religion within an empire.
The Roman empire existed before and what
he was talking about was all religion.
Where as Mohammad on
the phone did an empire,
we forget.
Yes.
Right.
That's a very important distinction.
I mean it really,
and it made might be the crucial
distinction sort of speak the crucial
distinction.
Yeah.
And there was this empire and this empire
bows and decline and fell and those
who feel that they have
inherited that legacy,
they want to go back to
the days of [inaudible].
Yeah.
Go back to the days when his loud voice
to previous and they want to do this in
the 21st century.
Yeah.
All kinds.
It's not just that you called camp on
horseback and invade an existing empire.
The Byzantine like
easy and empires.
This,
he took off and you could
just take things off.
It's not like that,
but they're driven.
They're convinced.
They have this legacy and
they're not afraid of death.
And how is key because,
and here's why I keep going back to Dow.
All Muslim children learn that
life on this as this temple.
Yes.
As your tree.
And that there is something
in the here then this,
there's no point in investing
in this life except in,
and they just started that.
So for the Medina Muslims,
it really becomes easy to recruit
and inspire into their parents.
Muslims who have already been taught
that if they've only got to work for the
hereafter problems with Islam.
And I think it was,
we understand that of course,
the basic LMS,
Mohammed Straw,
all of the Koran,
the fall of the he after all of
these things and what should it mean?
And then it gets to the Dow accounts.
This is how they manage
to teach young people.
How do they manage the teachable for
these thousands and millions of people who
is subsidizing these
countries like Saudi Arabia,
Qatar.
We understand that.
I think it makes our job
as westerners western last,
whatever's easiest.